i still live in media
it's a news overload
during these uncertain times we all
strive for some sort of normalcy
like sticking to some sort of routine or
just finding
just some joy in the simple things in
life so naturally when i heard that
baseball was coming back
i was ecstatic i mean i was absolutely
excited about watching my
beloved cubs from the comfort of my own
home
while the world outside is crumbling
last week was the cubs home opener no it
wasn't
and i said to myself wow wow they really
went through with this okay mlb
congratulations that you got some
but to my disappointment i find out
that these games are subjected to
something called the blackout rules
and that the majority of the season was
going to be cockblocked
by somebody called the marquee sports
network
a blackout basically means that a local
channel owns the exclusive rights to
play a certain amount of games during
the season
now the [ __ ] part is that the
blackout usually applies to the hometown
area
that the team resides in i mean look at
this goddamn map
you're telling me if you live anywhere
in the pacific northwest
all the way through idaho you can't
watch a goddamn mariners game you can't
watch the rockies
in the goddamn rockies we might as well
start a new canada over here with this
[ __ ] we got the oakland athletics
they get a little dot
good for them across the bridge going to
san francisco watch the game there
who cares this is uh like a
like an abstract painting of greed so
basically for me
since i live in chicago this area right
here i gotta subscribe to some
cable network that carries marquee
sports network
so here's some quick history about our
lovable losers in the past 72 years you
could watch most of the cubs games for
free on the wgn network
now since wgn is a nationally
broadcasted channel
they played the cubs all across the
country for free so you could definitely
attribute that
to the reason why the cubs have a
national following like all across the
nation we have a huge following
i mean i'm sure most of you heard who
harry kerry is hello
now what i didn't know was that the
relationship with the cubs and wgn
ended last season meaning no more free
games on wgn
which up until now was inconceivable to
me sure you might say that nobody
watches regular tv in 2020 but at least
you have the option to watch it
for free online somewhere somebody's got
to be streaming it right
so the mlb claims that these archaic
blackout rules
were to encourage the fans to turn off
the tube and come watch the games live
at the stadium
okay fair enough never mind that there's
a goddamn pandemic going on outside
and the fans aren't even allowed at the
stadiums anyways okay
forget about that or let's not even get
into how you probably
spend a couple of hundred bucks just to
watch the game from the [ __ ]
foul pole let's not talk about that
let's talk about how wrigley field
has a capacity of 41 000 in a city of
2.7 million people i mean even
wrigleyville itself
has a hundred thousand people living in
it the average attendance
of a cubs game in 2019 was 38 thousand
208 so you want to [ __ ] block over a
million potential viewers
just so you could try to fill in 3441
seats
here's a tip commissioner how about you
lower the cost of the overpriced tickets
you
dummies now the more i looked into this
the more i realized
how transparent the real motive was the
marquee sports network was trying to get
me
to nag my cable provider into carrying
their stupid channel reach out and ask
what the [ __ ] am i
some sort of door-to-door jehovah's
witness out here doing the lord's work
for the marquee [ __ ] sports network i
don't know if you heard but there's a
goddamn pandemic still raging through
the goddamn country
now at this point i had to direct my
anger and whoever was responsible for
this atrocity
so after a little bit of internet
sleuthing i find out
that the marquee sports network is owned
by my beloved cubs themselves out of the
betrayal
[Music]
so i pace around a little bit i get it
together you know
drink a little tea relax so here i am on
opening day
a game is a game and i'm just glad that
it's on you know even when life throws a
curveball at me
i can hit that home run out the park
schwarber on the wavelength you know
what i'm saying
i still got it i'm looking up where to
watch this game
i see marquee sports network so i google
what the [ __ ] is a marquee sports
network oh it's a channel only available
to rcn and directv customers
okay great let me just get on the horn
real quick and switch cable providers
you gritty [ __ ]
what kind of sick and sadistic [ __ ] is
this huh you're telling me a casual
viewer in new york
can stream any of the games live while a
hometown fan in chicago is just [ __ ] out
of luck
are y'all trying to make baseball more
unpopular
so listen mlb the cubs organization
spectrum sinclair marquis sports network
viacom i don't even care who's
responsible anymore
you just you got to fix it you got to
make this right
cause what you're doing is evil
and there's a pandemic going on outside
it's just
it's not right fix it
commissioner tear down this goddamn wall
but most importantly let's not forget
this is our national pastime we're
talking about and we need it now
more than ever as our country suffers
through these unsettling times
make it right thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right cubs are up two to one let's
go
solomon media